16 грудня 2014 року вийшло в історію русі
їх чорний with the rock to die рубль
обвали все ще до долара через падіння
ціна на авто за провід женя захисних
санкцій за газ три дні конфлікту на
Після України привносить тому ситуація
Така повторюються курс рубля до долара
знову впав і зігнувши і стійкого мінімуму
з 98 го року дежавю
але зовсім віджати його падіння рубля
ви іклана фактично шоу не нею прочитали
але й падінням цін на нафту поважаючи
німецький експерт виробок на 2 see the
саудівської аравії та d повним ходом через
надмірного проповідь вона наступала з 55
доларів у vrs немає опік не до 37
доларів за 1 з таким розвитку mp1 та в
пори та ціані російський бюджет вони
російська економіка США за втомиться і
wrong one or can set the value to all
росії пасти ну дура школа ранку поза
долар кіт вал вище 50 рублів а то
пориві потрібно доріжки вигляд 73 рублів
падіння курсу рубля це означає
експерти з канави буваєте на рейтингу
влади
алип означається на добро будь і
ревінь реальних доходів вибухають
інфляція за російська економіка
у середньо струг away перспективі солодкий
рубль webasto малювати експорт для бухти
економіть вибрати з іскри за 1 для тіла
москві на громаду гаранту вата іноземним
інвесторам за хост влади а також
мін це своє сонячне поле так поважаючи
andreas мініки їжа холодна війна між
росією і сша і нато цеповяза нас
підйомів сиру це україні та ряду росії
на оксидів жид і пивних заходиш щоб
повернути туди віру та наземних інвестору
експорт прогнозу ще доступна в руку
курс рубля стабілізується та шви чизів
ланцюга дрізд і проте при 20 ортіс долара
та євро на його думку складно за принципами
хочеш 10 зі знижкою кішку в цьому рубль
з китайськими кішками на авто